okay so just to give them a little
background you're in your 50s uh you're
you're almost 80. yeah so obviously like
the world was different when you guys
were dating gosh oh yeah it's so much
different yes oh so I'm curious what was
life like when are you guys still
married
we were Plum a widow right now yeah but
my husband and I were married and
64. okay 1964.
so
it um I'm trying to think like what was
it just go ahead what was dating like
when you were looking for a husband
oh
yeah how did you meet Ron well it was a
blind date okay and so I met my husband
and we went out on a few dates and we
got along
and that it just began
on romance
he went to school of course and I
supported him and and then when he was
done we got married and
um
now talking about children my daughter
my oldest daughter has six children wow
and then my other daughter has three
so they really wanted to have children
when they were married
you know they didn't hold back
or whatever so yeah yeah and then I uh I
would say
I was raised Catholic and that was a big
piece of how I went about dating and I
met my husband which I'm divorced uh
but I met him in in high school and so
we met at 15 married at 22 10 years I've
been divorced so we were together 30
years
um he was you know like 30 years yes wow
because we met so young we got and I
feel like now on the other side 30 years
is was good you know that's like a
lifetime for a lot of people were were
you guys did you care about money when
you were dating were you like looking at
how much they made because I do I
interview young women a lot and I hear
that he needs to make like x amount of
dollars in order to be with me no no no
no no for me no it wasn't it wasn't an
issue at all no you this is the thing is
I think we both met our husbands when
they were young men and we were allowing
for the growth right they're not going
to be we're meeting them when they're
young 20 they're not going to have money
they're learning to be a man and make
money they're going to school you hope
they'll be successful
so basically you're looking to the
gentleman that will be will be after a
while you're not looking at okay I'm
cool and see right now because you've
never Marion so what what kind of traits
were you like looking for in a husband
like what like if you add back then like
what were the top like five traits maybe
well I'm canceled
so so that's too Catholics
you know I was hoping that my husband
would have the same
beliefs as me and he is cat he was
camping so that was important that kept
us together our faith was very important
so anything else yeah what other um what
other aspects of Iran did you like
um as a Young Man
that made you think it was very
intelligent
you know he he was really something he
could
fix anything
do pretty much anything
he was electrical engineering wow and he
he was just quite a gun you know
and I admired that in him so much
and um
he was you know
just a real great guy I can't think of
all the attributes now but that the same
values I think the same values was was a
is a good point I would say that I was
looking for that as well
my husband sense of humor for me was big
and determination he was very determined
to become
and you know he had some
different jobs in that that found it and
then he went in the army
and he he just kept going and it was
very he's an I.T guy now and
um
I think the sense of humor though we had
a good time together and I want to say
that the whole sexual thing was not
happening okay I know what what's going
on now with even my daughter you know
that they're not dating
they're having sexual relations with
each other before they even know each
other really and I really not
at all
that that's necessary
um that wasn't something that came into
play
when you're dating and trying to find a
partner that
that wasn't the biggest thing and the
money wasn't the biggest thing either it
was more who they were
as a person when did you notice a switch
like from people dating more
intentionally to get married versus like
pushing marriage off like when did you
notice
like though the men and the young men
and the young women started dating
differently
I would say what that my kids generation
okay so yeah so when they're my oldest
is 32. so
you know when he when he was down you
know in early 20 year old and then on so
what is that 2000 2000s yeah what about
you when did you notice it
probably about the same time you do yeah
when you know
so it wasn't with our generation no like
with your children right right
it's more your grandchildren
my grandchildren yeah yeah
why do you think like women and men
aren't getting married anymore
you want to answer that well
I think part of it could could be
selfishness
that they're thinking of
themselves
and not realizing
how happy they could be
with a family and children
yeah I know they just don't that's a
good point don't put a value on that
right
and it's a commitment and it's um
compromising and it's
um giving up
a lot of yourself
for somebody else and eventually
children
them if they want to do that really what
do you what do you think of women
because I hear this from girls a lot
they'll be with the guy for a couple
years and say they've like lost
themselves
I saw a girl on the show she was um with
a guy for three years and
um he he was a good guy she said yeah
but she left him because she felt like
she was like losing herself oh
you
do that I shouldn't
I don't know
this world is so different it is so
different it's so different it's also
what's around because I I understand
that because being divorced I understand
that uh looking back I I also lost
myself but you just becoming a different
person is what it is and I think that's
scary to a lot of people
but when you're talking about having a
partner and dating the other person has
to also
um be open to you being and doing so the
woman doesn't feel like she's losing
herself if she wants to do art or some
outrageous thing and that's considered
outrageous but it's not if you're just
doing something your creative side would
like you to do and uh Partners not up
for it or what it's it's hard to go
through life
uh with two people
and to have other people's putting
having input because then you have to be
compromising and you do have to be
willing to Lose Yourself somewhat that's
part of it if you're going to be
partners for life
that's part of it so I do understand
that
because it does happen but that doesn't
mean it's a bad thing yeah that's my
time yeah that's right I would think of
it too it's like you kind of Lose
Yourself you you could lose yourself
with your friends like you're gonna do
things you don't want to do if you have
a friend yes so you would think if
they're a husband like of course you're
going to do things you don't want to do
yes yes
um yeah so you know a key element that's
I think missing is communication between
people I don't think girls and guys
communicate
in a healthy manner which is why you
have the ghosting and the why aren't you
just talking to each other why are why
is this happening why can't you just be
upfront and honest with each other I
don't
you want to so you want to know an
interesting some interesting numbers
that might put some things in the
perspective yes so you know
um a hundred percent of women like want
20 percent of men and the number one way
that people are meeting nowadays under
30 is dating apps but what women don't
what women don't know is that when
you're on a dating app
um if you match with the guy women only
swipe right five percent of the time so
the issue is that women
um like a girl that's like you know it
starts with looks right so it's like a
girl that's like maybe a five a six or a
seven is matching with a guy that's a 10
or a nine and she's not getting the call
back because he's out of her League okay
but there's no like before the families
would kind of know like that's the bad
boy or like stay away from right you
know yeah like the dads would like hide
the dog you know but now it's like it's
almost like free Reigns and the issue is
like all the women are sleeping with a
very small percentage of men wow it's
like 10 20 percent
um so they're not really like finding a
husband because if you're a guy and
you're getting a hundred percent of
women are you gonna settle down right no
no no and the other men are sexless so
they're seeing a growing trend of like
men that aren't sleeping with anybody
and where so it's almost like we're
going back to like non-monogamy yeah
it's almost polygamy in a way oh no I
didn't
do you do you know any women that didn't
have kids
uh by what age though
like never had children
like all my friends from my age group
they all have children and all my
friends I grew up with and yeah went to
college yep they all have kids do you
think women can be happy without
children no yes yes yeah
thank you
I don't think so because that's part of
who a woman is
is to give
um
is to give birth to a child
they have all the mechanisms they have
everything in their bodies yes and
supposed to be used
for what
forbearing children for having children
a sign of love between them and their
partner
my thought is is that there are way too
many people just having kids anyways
that don't hurt
not to be parents
women that have
I mean I'm not going to name names but I
know that have had children
and just under pressure to have and they
don't want
to be a mother really so what what does
that's not setting up their kids for a
healthy
environment growing up learning so the
women you're you don't have to say names
but the women you're thinking of like
were they career women like wives oh
okay yeah and they felt like they had to
give that up to be a mother actually
um this gal did not give it up okay so
that was part of it and it you know it's
I don't think that you can have the best
of both worlds either I really don't I
don't think we that's where our society
is going and some of the issues
it's my opinion that a lot of it is a
woman please if you decide to have
children make sure that you're willing
to give time to be a mother right
because you cannot do full-time
everything and take care of yourself it
doesn't happen and you have to be able
to take care of yourself
to be the kind of woman that you need to
be to be a good mother
good partner
and
if you want to be a good employee be
that too but
the thing is is a lot of women have uh
worked hard
at getting where they're at they've gone
through school they've they've done a
lot of work but they should be allowed
to then use that it's not it doesn't
make sense
so I can see why women don't want to
have kids and at a certain point you're
too old right so
um
I I think I understand that I understand
that yeah do you think women can work
and be a mother
uh I think well you did well but part
time your time you make it you can you
know they have to
realize that they have a job maybe I
shouldn't call it a job they have a
responsibility to their children their
home you know they can work I mean look
at now what how it is you can work from
home from remotely
and um that's a big asset from um you
know dads to be able to do that
but
yeah they just they can do that they can
work and then have children
but children are the primary
you know yeah should be number one
non-priority priority yes what do you
guys think of moms that are on social
media
is that okay is that good is that bad in
what like um that post like pictures of
themselves like like bikini pictures
online
I don't even go on social media
no I don't think that's right yeah yes I
know yeah and I I think it's fine I mean
I don't you think it's fine to post
pictures of yourself
[Applause]
building sand castles
or you're that kind of thing I don't
like I don't like it when they're making
it about themselves maybe is is what it
is but we're naked no I would not want
to see him naked either but I'm pretty
sure
Instagram
pretty sure that would get blocked
immediately taken down whatever
I know yeah oh wow how has the world
changed before and after social media
it's a nightmare it's a nightmare don't
you say it's a nightmare
yeah yeah it is I mean but you don't
think that ass pictures are good for the
world
yeah or your objections to make an ass
so you can put it on Instagram no I know
no we shouldn't go to Miami and just you
know get the botox no no I don't think
that's healthy for single women either
to be thinking that they need to present
that sort of image you know we're moving
towards better mental health we're
moving towards better uh healthy body
image accepting I think that is a great
piece but it's always overrun by all the
other garbage there's a few things here
and there that social media is really
good
it is the connection
things that can be good but it gets
overrun by all the negative for sure so
that's what I think and I don't watch it
a lot you know
I don't know sweetie you don't and yeah
she sees enough on CNN
see yeah man yeah
what do you what do you what do you
think of all the girls getting the Botox
and the injections you don't you know I
think it's silly a waste of time and
money but Hey listen who am I to saying
I mean who am I to judge it's not really
for I I don't I don't think that I don't
think we would consider doing that
that's the thing but mind you we're in
Northern Illinois and this is like you
know we grew up more you know farm and
small town and even Crystal Lake which
is large now is small back then it's
crazy how much everything's grown even
coming back like from growing up here
I'm I'm by 47. okay and it's like crazy
it used to just be the Walmart yeah
everything now and yes yeah well thank
you guys very much this was welcome it's
so insightful I love talking to it I
love like I I was 13 when social media
came so I've never really known the
world without it I'm sorry I'm really
sorry it's almost like ancient times to
us like what was the world like with
people this is the thing is the people
now you guys and even the younger that
you only know the world you're growing
up in yeah like we know a previous world
and this world and that's why and I'm
sorry but once you start getting old you
don't want to change and then change
so you get a lot of uh feedback that's
negative from the older older people but
well a lot of the news that is on TV I
find myself
in that error
and at that time I live down the south
side of Chicago
I remember when's Grime squirrels oh
yeah because we're killed
my friends and I did and how we were so
so petrified and so crazy you you
remember I do not because I was much I
was probably a baby or not even born yet
but these were sisters they were sisters
that were walking home that were killed
by a serial killer and that happened wow
I remember how afraid that I was and all
my friends
you know because in those days you could
walk down the street
and not worry about anybody around you
you know and we were we were pretty
afraid about that but I'm just trying to
being a bring up the point that in those
days
you know I remember those times and they
were pretty scary
and now we're facing
times now which are just and scary
with all God
you know killings and things happening
it's a shame it's terrible yes
they're crying I've never even heard of
that actually yeah yeah look it up
because yeah
wgm yeah she watches WGN
yeah
just you know uh you know they're
running their 75th Anniversary which is
why he says she thinks of her growing up
when she sees things well it's gonna be
it's kind of crazy to think of how the
World's Gonna Be With My Generation not
having kids it's even I just went to
church and I was like well there are no
kids here like that it's like all people
like 35 and up I would say mostly like
the younger generation we're not in
church well there will be an impact
there's always going to be an impact by
the Next Generation making their own
choices so
that the whole um people not being uh in
uh committed to a religion will have an
impact only you guys in in the next
people who are having kids will see that
you know what happens with that oh I
forgot to ask you guys what do you guys
think of submission
do you guys believe that women should
submit to men in relationships
I don't no oh no no no
I know that's part of the the Bible and
all that but that's not
it's a give and take and so yes you
should be listening to your partner but
he as well should be listening to you in
any good marriage is going to have
respect going both ways it's not going
to make it that's it no
that's okay
up until a certain point it's just
interesting how that like it seems like
that kind of went away you know like I
I'd imagine you could tell me if I'm
wrong but it seems like in previous
generations like it was kind of like
what your husband said goes at the end
of the day and it seems like it's kind
of like lost where now we're in this
we're like men and women have equals
right yes but it doesn't seem to work
better like it seems like yeah
well but that's going to happen because
the women have found their voice and
their independence and that's what I was
saying with the marriage thing men and
women don't have to get married yeah
women don't have to submit and and be uh
you know sold or whatever married off or
I mean for goodness sake here's a dowry
you have a cow and a goat and take my
daughter yeah I mean it doesn't that
doesn't even make any sense anymore and
women work too hard to be
having any of that
which is good that's a good thing that's
a good thing what do you think good
thing bad things yeah
okay yeah I don't think any of us think
women should be no not having a voice
right no right yeah
well thank you guys I appreciate it